speaking of this doesn't matter Brendan
Dilly
um
Christina Pusha our good friend
Christina blue shot tweeted out yes and
no matter what the views are about
politics are there is no justification
for anyone to make sexualized comments
and photoshops of women who are just
expressing their opinion the gutter
trash behavior only comes from low-class
morons who aren't capable so they're
doing the same same thing where they're
photoshopping Christina Pusha like you
know like us [__] and like all that
stuff so that's what she's commenting
now for those there's some new people
here some people some of you people like
that so many people like us like him
because you guys aren't [__] nerds
but
um Brendan Dilly is someone that we've
covered for a long time now Brendan
Dilly is of course a cringe machine and
for those people that don't know because
he's pivoted he's pivoted oh is he
pivoted into he's on cringe machine no
he's still a cringe machine I'm sorry
sometimes you could have you you know
when they tell you to turn into the skid
he turned into the cringe oh nice so no
but he was Brendan Dilly was a guy who
um is a guy
who said that he had ins that he was
literally talking with by the way nice
dandruff on your face and on your
shoulder um that's why they made the
video black and white
um let me just make the video again why
did you not make the video
a lot of solutions here Brendan you
[__] nerd and we're just spiff on
that took us two seconds yeah so anyway
this [__] by the way professional
parking lot attendant we don't forget
um he has been you know he's of course
defending Trump now he was a guy who
said that he had Direct contact with Q
remember that Dilly drops he called them
he leaned into the Q Anon stuff which is
[__] [__] by the way leaning into
all the Q Anon stuff and he was just
[__] pretending that even if people
that believe the Q Anon stuff didn't
like him because he was pretending like
he had inside knowledge that Trump knows
who he was his biggest claim to fame was
that he had Roseanne on his show
remember that oh God she did the Dilly
show he's a [__] hack he blocked Us
in every account he's ever had he's a
[__] will never address us he sells
stroke spoons
uh remember House of Maga Game of
Thrones thing he has on his wall
so that's you're you're you're like
knocking some [__] loose that I'm like
yeah it's been a while I mean it is it
has been a while it has been a while
since we brought up uh since we brought
up old Dilly here you go oh Christina
Bashaw someone should have reminded you
that the people that you're being
offended by the people who are laughing
at the [__] memes of your horrendous
team okay well now this first let's stop
with this start with this
so I just to be clear Brendan you are
fine with people making funny memes
right and funny photoshops
but no no no no no no no no no warlord
Dilly Jesus Christ what a [__] cringe
machine
um
that's all I needed to hear for that
we're going to keep playing it but we
should make sure that that's now on
record you're cool with it right you're
cool with it cool okay you weren't cool
at it in the past but now you're saying
now you're cool with it okay cool all
right
the people who are [__] posting you into
Oblivion and making fun of you by the
way she is not being [__] posted into
Oblivion there's just as many people
[__] defending her he's making it
seem like all the DeSantis people are
getting dunked on and they're not no of
course you know I I have to say though
this is one of those uh hate hate
situations this one is ROTC patented
totally not an Adonis Paul bit uh
trademark this might be a hate hate
because her in the first place her
argument's like oh wow you're really I
agree with that sexualizing yeah you're
a political operative Christina you
wanted to it's quote more leave you from
The Wire you wanted to be in the game
now you're in the game that is
um you know I I totally agree [__]
with people's families and kids that
[__] should be off limits but if you're
in the [__] game you can't be
standing on a street corner selling
crack and get mad when you catch a few
bullets right like sorry
but Billy also sucks and you're not
memeing them into Oblivion which you
[__] need you can't win without Mega
votes and you can't get those votes
because your candidate you're right you
can't win without Mega votes I agree
with that
but Trump can't win without Florida yeah
forget about Florida Trump can't win
without a lot of former Mega votes
that's the problems
net gain people he hasn't yeah there's a
lot of people spread out around the
country all of Trump's original 2016
cheerleaders are gone are gone except
for Loomer yeah you lost everybody dude
you lost [__] uh Ann Coulter you're
losing Bannon you lost all the early
alt-right people in 2016. they're all
fawning over Kanye trying to get [__]
likes on Tick Tock like you've lost it
it just turned you let it turn into a
flea market and you let the dillies of
the world take it over and now that's
all it is it's just rows of booths full
of cheap merchandise for sale [__]
[__] coffee because it's Patriot
coffee and [__] shitty ass [__]
dumb memes and hats that say me more
veteran and hats that say make insert my
podcast great again and [__] Trump
bears and nfts and a [__] look at it
that's what it is now it would be less
cringe if it was funko pop dolls behind
you yeah seriously okay shall we break
that before we hit play shall we break
down his setup
I think we shall Pepe frog with a Maga
hat Trump bobble head up there at the
top left I was like okay there's like
everyone if you see something call it
out Trump bobble head okay I see the
Trump bobble head uh what do we got here
a licorice some sort of licorice thing
that he's selling a bag of soda
yeah yeah that's what I was looking at
right there uh Mega soda uh Mean Tweets
mug oh I mean tweets my got it okay cool
cool hey I have a question you've been
doing this for a long time oh Dilly with
Trump hair
yeah oh here's the thing by the way so
you guys know
you've been doing this for a long time
buddy you still using [__] one of
those shitty microphones huh
that's here let's hear him
if you can and team Trump
while team Trump goes out of their way
behind him
hey I put it I put a Dilly demon hey
look it looks like there's a Dilly sauce
behind him too you think if you peel
that label back as a [__] ROTC
revenge of the sauce you think our guy
got in there you want me to make that
that mic worse for you sure you want me
to make it work that's an sm58 yeah
that's not a bad mic well hold on why
does it hold on hold on then why does it
sound like this nearly Americans like
myself tomorrow to help her kick off the
president's campaign it's so over
modulated wow you're a teeny tinny boy
huh get yourself cans if you're gonna
have headphones in number one number two
let me help it's been years since we
covered and we go right back into it we
just help let me help you daily please
let us help you all right mister what
how you doing on Rumble I haven't even
checked uh ten thousand followers that's
adorable
um what no I'm just saying and follows
it up with another invite to support the
president after his indictment [__] it's
so over modulated
hey Dilly you're a [__] hack
you're a parking lot attendant you're a
grifter and you're such a deep Griff
that you'll move on to the next thing
are you still hanging out with the
clothes the corpse of JFK Jr what was
that yeah right I remember I don't
remember other than a [__] bunker
listen as soon as [__] settles and
[__] DeSantis pulls ahead in the
primaries you will be sucking from his
tit like ever you will be lining up to
blow that guy like everyone else if you
think that the crowds move in a certain
way and the merchandise is moving a
certain way when Ron DeSantis starts
selling more hats than Trump whole
Tilly's gonna have all Ronda Santa's app
on him make America Florida man watch
mark my words
I'm predicting it
stop it you sold stroke spoons you're
[__] what is his live reads now let's
see oh here I got some
here you go no I don't expect to get it
anytime [__] soon I'm
I'm like number 2 800 on the list and
frankly I can't afford the goddamn car
right now anyway
wait what's up I'm sorry big big dollars
what happened big but money box what is
he so is that a [__] Corvette yeah
he's on the list for the new Z06 I think
Corvette Corvettes yeah and he says that
he's not can't afford it anyway but I'm
sorry I still want one really really bad
if you're gonna get him really bad like
if you're gonna put an over modulating
loser if you're gonna sit on a waiting
list and you're gonna buy a car which I
will admit that the new Corvettes do
look cool
they're still Corvettes and for as much
as they cost because I looked up one day
to see him I was like those look kind of
nice but that's probably and I looked up
like the price of a Corvette nowadays if
you're going to go into that [__]
price range and you're gonna get on a
waiting list and you're waiting on a
Corvette you're a [__] douchebag you
are the douchiest douche that ever
douched you're gonna spend like 80 grand
and be on a waiting list you get
something European you get something for
me you get some kind of cool [__] car
bro
hey you get a Hyundai Sonata for 25.
calm down everybody with your big
purchases